this job is eating me alive
i can't breathe anymore
i spent all these years trying to be the
good guy
the man in the white hat
i'm not becoming like them
i am them hey
what are you doing weirdo i'm doing the
best speech from donnie brasco or
actually
ten of me are doing the best beach from
donny brasco
what's up
get it together man okay
so the store was hit about two hours ago
they took mostly tablets laptops and
cameras
[Music]
sorry
i'd like a list of all your employees
whoever had access to the store i'd also
like to apologize for my partner his
parents and give him enough attention uh
detective i already solved the case
we're looking for three white males one
of whom has sleeve tats on both arms and
how do you know that i had an informant
on the inside
he's been here for years watching
learning
waiting
his code name
fuzzy cuddle bear
he's an anacam ah you got lucky no i got
here five minutes before you and figured
that in this gigantic electronic store
there had to be at least one working
camera
oh hi bad guys you did it fuzzy you
busted them
it's time to come home
i'm not sure if i can
i've been undercover so long i've
forgotten who i am i have seen terrible
things i haven't known the touch of a
woman in many moons all right
detective santiago
don't walk away from me
look you know i was scared about having
kids because i didn't want to be like my
dad
but if i do this
i have a chance to be the exact opposite
and i don't want mac to ever feel the
way i felt growing up and i get that i
really do
but you love being a detective
i know
it's all i ever wanted to be
until now
now
all i care about is what's best for our
family and ames this is it
i mean you've earned this incredible
opportunity you can't do it halfway it's
too important and mac's my little buddy
i want to be at home with him
are you sure
because we could figure something else
out you know i would do anything for you
i would do anything for you too
will you run that half marathon i'm
never running the half marathon amy you
gotta stop asking
you really think you'll be happy
i don't want you to give up your dream
job just for me i have a new dream job
now
trust me i wouldn't say it if i didn't
mean it
i love you
i love you too
so
we're good
yeah we're good oh thank god i spent so
much money on this plan how much money
jake i mean i didn't insane i'm not mac
definitely has to go to state college
now but the important thing is we're on
the same page sorry dude but this new
guy is going to be another washed up
pencil pusher he's only concerned with
following every rule and the patrol
guide meet morph z
robot captain engage is that what you
think hey
new captain alert
you must be the new ceo i'm detective
jake peralta great to meet you no don't
let me interrupt you we're describing
what kind of person i'm going to be i'd
like you to finish
it's not necessary
or i could recap very quickly sure um
let's see
i think i said some joke about being a
washed up pencil pusher now do the robot
boys
wait the robot voice you were doing when
you were implied i'm a rule-following
robot i want to hear it again
me more
serp
robot
that's a terrible robot boys yep
so
you're leaving
that must be a hard decision honestly
it wasn't it's funny
on my first day here i asked jeffords to
tell me about everyone told me you were
a great detective but the one thing you
couldn't figure out was how to grow up
well
i think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir i couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as uh something
of a father figure did i i didn't
realize that but i want you to know if i
had had a son
and uh
it turned out like you
i would be very proud of him
thanks sir
wow
wasn't expecting me to get this
emotional it's not bad for an old robot
huh
keep morph sleep
sir did you just make a joke i believe i
did yes i guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a bit
tyler's sex movie
did i do that right
it was perfect
hey rosa rosa rosa um
i i just happen to notice that uh
there's an old movie festival play at
the film forum this week
you want to go
sure
cool awesome there's a bunch of movie
options i'll probably just go with
something classic like citizen kane
citizen kane is terrible pick a good
movie good call smart
i'll do it i'll pick a better movie than
citizen kane
i just want you to know that i don't
care if you end up with anyone or get
married or whatever i just want you to
be happy i am happy i'm making a
difference i've got great friends also
i'm moving in with my girlfriend debra
she is amazing she makes me feel whole
oh really oh my god this is too easy no
i don't want to settle down right i'm
sorry sorry it's fine i'm just messing
with you
it's crazy you're leaving
we spent a lot of time here yeah we did
i'm really happy it was with you
sam here
i love you
i love you too
hey gina you know any scalpers i want to
ask rosa to go to the rihanna concert
with me but it's sold out okay two
points to make here first rihanna
you and then rihanna
yeah what's your second point she's got
a type
which is really anyone but you
yeah that was my ex-wife's type too
look a rihanna concert's a pretty big
swing man i don't know she's into
watching old movies cool
where would i find a place to chose old
movies oh yeah just go on the internet
and search for the phrase i want to buy
two movie tickets for a girl who doesn't
like me great
thank you oh jake i can't believe you're
leaving
i mean it's not the nine-nine without
you i know but rosa's already gone and
holt and amy are moving on too is that
why you're doing this to fit in with
that crowd charles i just want to be
there for mac i get that but this whole
thing is just taking me by surprise i
don't know if i can come into work and
do this job without you are you kidding
me i mean maybe the you of nine years
ago couldn't handle it but you're not
that person anymore you used to live in
your ex-wife's husband's basement and
date 75 year olds and now you've got
your own house and genevieve and nikolaj
nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj nikolaj
why don't you just call him nick nick
all right now you're ruining the moment
i'll be there
sergeant you were in the 1-8 with me
though you were significantly
fatter sir they called me cherry titties
because i had
large uh titties yes i remember
i never liked that nickname
though to be fair it was accurate what
since i hear about you being on
administrative leave a year ago my wife
and i had twin baby girls um
cagney and lacy they have adorable
chubby cheeks ever since i kind of got
scared of getting hurt lost my edge
there was an incident in a department
store
hey man you okay you look a little
chubby i'm fine i'm fine
i think he's dead you all want the same
thing a perfect goodbye but you're all
getting in each other's way we are the
nine-nine
and we work best together and we're
getting out of here together so we're
gonna find that too and we're gonna be
crowned grand champions of the nine nine
together except for the ugly one that
made fun of my cello not now carolyn st
jacques renard i agree with jeffords
read the room carolyn st jack renard
great speech terry but we're kind of
trapped in here not for long
i'm gonna kool-aid man us the hell out
of here i thought you said that was
impossible it's not i just find it
demeaning it's actually very easy
[Music]
now go through that wall i'm not doing
any more walls jake we're free fair
enough i had to ask
you